demon souls is a 70 launch title for the
playstation 5
which hits stores on november 12th and
according to this trailer the game will
also be available for pc
and other consoles after a limited time
and they removed the trailer
it's not coming to other platforms they
lied sony was quick to put out a
correction
saying that demon souls is in fact a ps5
exclusive
i will say though announcing demon souls
for other platforms is a very specific
mistake to make
and i wouldn't be surprised if demon
souls actually is coming to pc
and xbox at a later date it's possible
they just announced it too early
remember sony is making an effort to
release some of their ips on pc
so it's possible either way though this
is a mess so
subscribe and stay tuned for more
information but let's jump into the
gameplay
vaulting like this has always been a
mechanic in demon souls but a lot of
people go through the game and
don't even realize it exists so that's
why they've added this walled off
section to the tutorial here
it forces you to learn about it which is
good tutorial design furthermore there's
a new ladder at the bottom here which
leads back up and this is our first
clue that bluepoint are open to tweaking
the level design
and i don't know if i'd call this a
level design change but the charred
timbers in this scene
foreshadow the dragon coming your way
and you can also barely see the other
side of this bridge now
thanks to the fog in demon souls fog and
fog gates are actually explained by the
law
the old one and its demons are spreading
the fog
which threatens to envelop the world and
now in the remake
many of the areas here are really foggy
a super fast
foggy warp animation seems to have
replaced loading screens
and some demons might visually be
spreading the fog
as the law says they're supposed to take
a close look at the fog emitting eyes
of the demon vanguard for example
putting aside how
insanely impressive the graphics are to
be able to spot something like this
i personally think fog is a tasteful
atmospheric addition to demon souls and
i think most people will agree that
the atmosphere here is better than what
we were shown a few months ago
the biggest criticisms of the first
trailer was the heroic atmosphere in the
tower night scene
the fluted knight armor and the generic
demon design of the flame lurker boss
well it seems like blue points are
listening
the tower knight fight now seems darker
the fluted knight armor is a bit more
fluted and the flame lurker has his old
face back
i think i speak for everyone when i say
well done blue point but i want to take
this opportunity to
bring up some of the new concerns that i
do have and
i think we should all take extra effort
to be really constructive with our
criticism because
blue points are listening and while none
of us have played the game
talking about this stuff now is our best
chance to make a difference before
release
first the camera a lot of people in my
stream said it feels a bit
off and i agree it's more cinematic it
sort of floats to the side of the
character sometimes
and it seems to lag behind movement a
little bit
which will be jarring for veteran
players the camera in souls is by no
means perfect
but i do find it odd that this is so
different when
so much of the gameplay is very
consciously being kept the same
for example and this is potentially
another criticism but it seems like
they've kept in the four-directional
locked-on rolling of demon souls
which in my opinion is the most dated
part of the original game
i think you can see this here during the
vanguard fight
and while it's impossible to confirm
this man can you imagine going back to
4-directional rolling
in this gorgeous next-gen game if you've
played a lot of demon souls and even a
lot of other souls games you'll probably
play locked off
a lot of the time for better positioning
and to open up more backstabs
even the player in this trailer plays
locked off a lot of the time
but for the sake of new players i think
being able to angle your role
into enemies while locked on is a huge
quality of life improvement that
they should consider if it's not already
in the game finally the presentation of
the trailer deserves a bit of criticism
it is weird that the player one hits
everything even through shields
the game will not play this way enemies
in the tutorial don't die this easily
so it was kind of weird that they chose
to present it this way
now there are more good things to say
than bad the updated music sounds great
and even the narration here is new
[Music]
so they're either bringing on a new
voice acting cast
or they're re-recording the original
voice actors i can't quite tell with the
maiden but
whoever she is she's doing a great job
with her lines and
that fills me with hope the sound design
is seeing huge changes too
i like the whisper of spirits when you
absorb souls
and your character actually makes a lot
of noise while they're running and
fighting now
this sort of character immersion is
interesting i worry that it might be a
bit distracting but i'll have to see how
it feels
but one thing i do hope that they do is
to have the character exertion
sounds in human form but to have the
character be quiet
in soul form enemies also seem more
vocal which
can be good for your sort of 3d
awareness of them but if you do see them
you'll notice that their faces are
contorting
as they attack and that their weapons
and shields now drop from their lifeless
hands once they're defeated
either that or they ricochet around the
room like crazy
it's one of the two backstabs now
feature a cruel
twist which i like and reposts pick up
your enemy and slam them down
which i like a little bit less but it's
okay overall
the trend here if you're noticing it is
that there is a lot more of our
character on display
here and i'm cautiously optimistic to
see how that
feels in a lot of subtle ways blue
points are putting
some of their own character into the
game which i feel like is their right
because they are clearly putting a lot
of effort into this remake
if i wanted to play a carbon copy of
demon souls
i would play the original i personally
don't mind but some people will
on top of it being 4k 60 frames per
second you can see the next gen graphics
in this torchlight which
is reflected and ray traced in a puddle
here i like the texture of the web on
you as you fight the armored spider
and the armored spider now spews oil to
sort of explain the slow fill of the
tunnel with flame
blood effects now splatter on yourself
and enemies
the shrine of storms is stormier and the
nexus looks amazing
speaking of which it's worth noting that
the sixth archstone
which relates to cut content from the
original game
still remains broken in the remake so i
still think it's very unlikely that
we'll see cut content restored for this
remake
some people are speculating about that
but i think it's very unlikely we'll see
that and i think it's very unlikely
we'll see dlc
as well because these things would
surely require from software's
involvement
and they don't seem to be that involved
that said blue points aren't averse to
adding new things like that to the game
a lot of you aren't gonna like this but
the game has a pre-order bonus where you
get the reaper's
scythe for pre-ordering which is a
weapon that's not in the original game
this is kind of worrying but i'm also
hoping it's a situation that was like
with dark souls 2
where the weapon is patched into the
base game at some point
i feel like that has to happen anyway
i'll be getting demon souls and a
playstation
5 at launch and i can't wait to explore
the game properly on the channel
in the depth and detail that demon souls
has always deserved
there's still a lot we don't know so
subscribe and i'll keep you up to date
with everything
in the months to come do you want to
listen to an audio book recommended by
miyazaki himself
it's called fever dream by george r.r
martin and by visiting audible.com or
texting
vaatividia to 500-500 you can listen to
it for free
during your 30-day audible trial so back
in june of last year
as a part of eldon ring's marketing
campaign
miyazaki answered a few questions about
the game and he talked a little bit
about his favorite book by george martin
saying i personally see fever dream as a
masterpiece among vampire fantasy
and had even previously recommended it
to all new employees
since then i obviously went on to listen
to it and
surprise it's really good it's about a
man named abner marsh who is a broke
steamboat captain who gets involved with
unsavory folk in order to mend his
finances have a listen to this excerpt
from audible the narration takes it to
the next level
laughter and loneliness and cruel
passion
york had all of that in his eyes but
mostly there was
force in those eyes terrible force a
strength is relentless and merciless as
the ice that had crushed marsh's dreams
it's a pretty easy listen too it's
nowhere near as intimidating as
something like
game of thrones and you'll soon
understand why it's so highly
recommended
so if you're keen to learn a little bit
more about the writing talent that is
behind
the law of elden ring then visit
audible.com
vaatividia or text vaatividia to 500-500
start your 30-day audible trial and you
can get fever-dream or any audiobook you
choose
and you'll also get unlimited audible
original monthly downloads
absolutely free if by some chance you
change your mind on fever dream
members also get easy audiobook
exchanges
so you have up to a year to exchange it
no questions asked
but thank you so much for listening and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you